[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اعلن الروس امس الموافق 9
نوفمبر 2022 قرارا مفاجاه بالانسحاب من
غرب مدينه خرسون الروس لم يكتفوا بالاعلان
عن انسحابه من غرب المدينه التي يعتبرونها
جزءا اصيلا من روسيا الاتحاديه منذ 30
سبتمبر الماضي ولكنهم اعلنوا عن انسحابهم
بشكل درامي خرج وزير الدفاع الروسي يقول
انه اعتمد قرار انسحاب الجنود بناء على
توصيه من الجنرال سيرجي صرفتين اللي هو
قائد العمليات العسكريه الروسي في
اوكرانيا وظهر الجنرال شرفكين ليقول ان
القرار لم يكن سهلا ابدا عليه لكنه اوضح
ان الدفاع عن خرسان اصبح امرا غير ممكن
واضاف ان قرار الانسحاب
سينقذ جنودنا والقدره القتاليه لوحداتنا
الاحتفاظ بهؤلاء القرود على الضفه الغربيه
من مدينه خرسون لم يعد امرا مقديا ويمكن
استخدامه الاستفاده من هيئه هؤلاء الجنود
على جبهات الاخرى الاعلان بالشكل الدرامي
ده طرح مجموعه من الاستفتاء علامات
الاستفهام على نوايا الروس ودوافعهم من
الانسحاب المفاجئ والدرامي من غرب مدينه
خرسون طبعا لما باقول همم ترعى علامات
استفهام وهنطرح سيناريوهات او احتمالات
تفسر القرار الروسي الاحتمالات معناها ان
انا نعلم الحقيقه ولا احد يعلم الحقيقه او
يستطيع ان يجزم بحقيقه ويروس
حقيقه نوايا الروس موجوده في عدد محدود
جدا من ادهان صناع القرار في روسيا لا
نملك الا محاوله التفسير واحنا قدام ثلاث
احتمالات في تقديري الاحتمال الاول ان
نصدق الروايه الرسميه الروسيه
وان نصدق ان الرؤوس عجزوا عن الدفاع عن
غرب مدينه خرسون وانهم فضلوا ترك هذه
المدينه
تقليلا للخسائر الحائله التي
منيت بها القوه الروسيه القوات الروسيه في
وضع صعب ومنيت بخسائر هائله منذ بدايه
العمليه الى الان الروايه الغربيه بتقول
ان رؤوس خسر حوالي 100.000 من جهودهم ممكن
تكون الروايه الغربيه مبالغ فيها ولكن ما
هو ليس مبالغ فيه هو ان القوات الروسيه
بنيت بخسائر كبيره حتى بالمعايير
وبالارقام والتخطيرات الروسيه طب ليه
الاحتمال ده محل شك ان هم انسحبوا تقليلا
لخسائره لانه لو كان انسحب فقط
لتقليل خسائره ما كان عليه ان يعلن عن هذا
الانسحاب بهذا الشكل الدرامي على شاشات
التليفزيون ما هي الرساله التي اريد ان
يعطيها الروس للاوكرانيين ولغرب وللعالم
خسرنا ونعترض بخصارتنا
وبنضطر للانسحاب لكن هذا اول احتمال
الاحتمال الثاني هو ان يكون هذا الانسحاب
المعلن بهذه الطريقه الدراميه ليس الافاخا
تنسحب القوات الروسيه ويعطي للانسحاب
مصداقيه باعلانه على لسان وزير الدفاع
وعلى لسان القائد العام للقوات الروسيه في
اوكرانيا سيهرع الاوكران الفريحين بنشوه
النصر الى المدينه فيبق عليهم الروس
ويحققون نصرا كبيرا هذا احتمال ثاني انا
اللي باقول الاحتمال الثاني ابدا اللي
بيقولوا الاوكراني المخابرات الاخرانيه
الرئيس الاوكراني بمجرد الاعلان بساعات
قليله خرجت تقديرات اوكرانيه تشكك في
الروايه الرسميه الروسيه وبيقولوا لم نرى
مؤشرات على انسحاب حقيقي من مدينه خرسون
وانه همم
الاعلان في التليفزيون قد يكون مجرد
تظليلا اعلاميا وجرنا او
اقتيادنا الى فخ يعني في غرب مدينه خيرسون
هذا امر وارد
وهيتضح اذا كان فخ ام غير فخ في القريب
العاجل خلال ايام المقبله وربما خلال
الدقائق التي اسجل فيها هذه الحلقه انا
اسجل هذه الحلقه في
ظهر يوم 10 نوفمبر 2000 و20 لكن في احتمال
ثالث هو ان الروس لا يريدون نصب كاملا
للقوات الاخرانيه
وليسوا عاجزين عن الدفاع عن مدينه خرسون
ولكن لهم يريدون خلق فرصه او اعطاء فرصه
لبدء مفاوضات بين الجانب الاوكراني
والجانب الروسي عشان نفهم الاحتمال الثالث
ده لابد من خلفيه سريعه والخلفيه السريعه
بتقول طبعا كل حرب بتنتهي بالفوضاات وكذلك
يدرك الروس والاكران ومن يقف وراءهم ان
الحرب اللي بدات فيه فبراير 2022 لا بد ان
تنتهي في المفاوضات مش ممكن تكون الحرب
مفتوحه الى الابد لكن اللي حصل في
الايام الخامسه من 30 سبتمبر الى اربعه
اكتوبر قتل احتمال المفاوضات على الاقل في
المدى المنظور ماذا حدث في الايام الخمس
من 30 سبتمبر لاربعه اكتوبر
في 30 سبتمبر اعلن الرئيس الروسي رسميا ضم
اربع مدن اوكرانيه الى الاتحاد الروسي
واصبحت اراضي روسيه اا يجب على الروس
حمايتهم كما يحموا كل اراضي روسيا الاتحاد
الاتحاديه المدن الاربعه اللي ذكرناها قبل
كده هي
جمهورتي الضمباز بالاضافه الى مدينه ذا
بوريجيا اللي فيها اكبر محطه نوويه لتعليم
لتوليد الكهرباء في اوروبا ومدينه خرسون
اللي هي بالاضافه الى اهميتها كمدينه هي
مصدر المياه التي تغذي شبه جزيره القرم
الروسيه منذ 2000 14
طيب اذا كان الرئيس الروسي قد اعلن الضم
حوالي 15%
رسميا من اراضي اوكرانيا الى روسيا
الاتحاديه كيف يمكن ان يتفاوض الاوكران
معه ادرك الاوكران انه المفاوضات شبه
مستحيله وجعلوا الاستحاله رسميا يوم اربع
اكتوبر حين اصدر الرئيس الاوكراني ظل نسكي
فرمانا قرارا بعدم جواز التفاوض مع الجانب
الروسي طالما ظل بوتن رئيسا ل همم روسيا
التطورات دي باختصار قتلت احتمال التفاوض
ولم يبقى الا احتمال استمرار الحرب لكن
هذا التطور قتل احتمالات التفاوض امر مزعج
جدا لحلفاء اوكرانيا من هم اهم حلفاء
اوكرانيا طبعا الولايات المتحده اللي
بتقود الجهود الغربيه وجهود حلف شمال
الاطلسي لدعم الاوكران امام الروس
الامريكان موقفهم تغير على مدار الشهور
الماضيه في بدايه الحرب كان هدف الامريكان
هو دعم الاوكران حتى يكون في موقف طويل
للتفاوض مع الروس عندما يجلسوا على مائده
المفاوضات في نهايه المطاف لكن زي ما قلت
لحضراتكم في عده مرات سابقه فوجئ الغرب او
هكذا يقولون ان اداء الجيش الروسي في بعض
في بدايه الحرب لم يكن عظيما خصوصا حين
فشل في همم يعني السيطره على مدينه على
العاصمه كيف و بدات ترتفع امالهم
وبداوا يضعوا اهدافا جديدا منها هزيمه
روسيا هزيمه مطلقه وبالتالي القضاء على
بوتن ثم بداوا يتراجعوا عن هذا الهدف لما
روسيا بدات تحقق انتصارات اكثر
وعاده الى هذا الهدف مره اخرى حين بني
الروس بخسائر متتاليه وبالتالي عاد الامل
الغربي او الاميركي في الحق هزيمه كامله
بالروس ثم ادرك الغرب مع طول امه الحرب ان
تحقيق انتصارا كاسحا وانتهاء هذه الحرب
بمنتصرا ومهزوم امر مستحيل تقريبا او حتى
لو كان ممكنا فلن يتم بخسائر مقبوله ابدا
لا خسائر مقبوله بين الاكران ولا بين
الاوروبيين ولا على العالم كله الحرب
بتدور في اوكرانيا لكن الجميع يدفع ثمنها
في شكل ارتفاع هائل في الاسعار تعاني منه
الدول الفقيره والغنيه
وبدات تتصاعد الضغوط على البيت الابيض
الضغوط من مين طبعا من العالم كله ده واضح
مبادرات من كل الدول في العالم تقريبا
لمحاوله التوسط لوقف الحرب لانهم بيعانوا
لكن اهم هذه الدول بياتو من الكتله
الاوروبيه نفسها اللي بتدفع الثمن الاكبر
واللي هي بتعني الامريكان اكثر من غيرهم
الاوروبيين قالوا للامريكان سرا وعلنا لا
نستطيع ان نتحمل حربا مفتوحه لشهور مقبله
يعني الخسائر خصوصا في الشتاء كانت تكون
كارثيه على الاوروبيين
الضغوط لم تاتي فقط من الخارج ولكن اتت من
داخل الولايات المتحده وبدات استطلاعات
الراي تقول ان الراي العام الامريكي فقد
حماسه الكبير لاستمرار الدعم لاكرانيا
يعني مثلا
استطلاع عن اجرته كيو اللي هي المؤسسه
الامريكيه المتخصصه في استطلاعات الراي
الف في سبتمبر يعني كان لسه بدري شويه مش
دلوقتي انه حماس الامريكان ليه او خوفهم
من الحق هزيمه باوكرانيا يتراجع بنسبه 55%
الى نسبه 38%
استطلاعات احدث يعني في اكتوبر الماضي
بتقول انه تاكل الاستطلاعات بتشير الى
تاكل
الرغبه في الدعم الاوكران بين الجمهوريين
تاكل الدعم
بين الجمهوريين لاستمرار المساعدات
الامريكيه بمعدلاتها الحاليه وطبعا
الجمهوريين دول باتوا اللي هم بياخذوا
الان حربا للسيطره على غرفتي الكونجرس
والمؤشرات بتقول انهم سيحتفظون باغلبيه في
العامين القادمين في مجلس النواب وربما
مفاجاه ويسيطرون على مجلس الشيوخ وبالتالي
رايهم بالغ الاهميه على العموم
التغير في الموقف الامريكي تغير من ايه من
دعم اوكرانيا حتى طالما انها قادره على
القتال وراغب فيه مهما تطلب الامر الى
لابد من ان يظهر الاوكران رغبه في التفاوض
لن تستمر الحرب للابد هذا هو التغير
التغير بدا يظهر في الايام القليله
الماضيه وشفنا مثلا صحيفه واشنطن بوست الى
نقلت عن مسؤولين امريكا
11 اكتوبر كانت نشره موضوع كبير عن كواليس
اجتماعات بيضين مع قاده العالم لحسين ما
عدد من قاده العالم لحذفهم على الاصطفاف
ضد روسيا في خمسه نوفمبر بعد حوالي ثلاثه
اسابيع نفس الصحيفه بتنشر كواليس الضغوط
الامريكيه على ظل نسكي لتخفيض توقعاته
واظهار رغبته في التفاوض هي واشنط
هذا الكلام ده كله الصحف الامريكيه
الكبيره تقريبا كلها نشرت ذلك ما يعني ان
الخبر لا يحتمل اي تجذيب يعني
في نفس الفتره كان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي في مفاوضات ما عدد من المسؤولين
مع ذلك نسكي وبيحاول الضغط عليه ليقنعه
بضروره القبول بالتفاوض في البدايه كان
موقف جيلنسكي لن نتفاوض على لسان بعض
مستشارين حتى لو تعرضنا لطعنه في الظهر زي
ما قال احد مستشاري لصحيفه ايطاليه من
الخلفاءنا لو تخلى عن حلفائنا فسوف نواصل
القتال لكن مع استمرار الضغط طبعا
سلم الرئيس اللينسكي بالضغوط الامريكيه
والضغوط الاوروبيه وقال انا مستعد للتفاوض
ولكن بشروط الشروط ديه عاليه جدا لانه
اشترط ان لكي يتفاوض ان ينسحب الروس من كل
الاراضي الاخرانيه ان يدفع الروس تعويضات
الاوكران ان يحاكم الروس المتورطين في
جرائم حرب طبعا دي لا يمكن شروط لا يمكن
ان يقبل بها الروس لكن الجديد في المساله
انه لم يذكر ابدا ان بدء المفاوضات مره
حور بتغيير القياده همم الروسيه بسقوط
الرئيس قطنا او تنحيه وفقا للمرسوم او
القرار الذي اتخاذه نشر في الجريده
الرسميه في اوكرانيا في اربعه اكتوبر
الماضي
طيب عاد الامريكان الان الى موقفهم القديم
انه دعمهم ليس مطلقا دعمهم ليس مستمرا
طالما ان الاوكران قادرين وراغبين في
استمرار القتال ولكن دعمهم
له هدف واحد وهو الدعم الاوكران لتحقيق
وضع جيد عند التفاوض مع الروس يعني لازم
يحققه بعض الانتصارات على الارض عشان يرغم
الروس على الجلوس معهم على مائده
المفاوضات ولما يجلسوا معه على عائله
المفردات يكونوا في وضع التفاوضيا جيد اذا
هدف العمليات العسكريه من جانب الغرب
واوكرانيا هو تحقيق وضع تفاعودي جيد لكنهم
يجلسون على مائده المفاوضات في نهايه
المطافئ الروس ايضا يرغبون في مفاوضات لان
الحرب المفتوحه مهلكه لهم وبالتالي الجميع
في انتصار في انتظار وضع يسمح لكل منهم
بالجلوس على مائده المفاوضات ولكن بشكل
يعني همم
داعم له على مائده المفاوضات
نعود الى الاحتمال الثالث الذي كنت احدثكم
عنه اذا لم يكن الانسحاب الروسي كاملا اذا
لم يكن كبينا واذا لم يكن عجزا من القوات
الروسيه عن الدفاع عن مدينه خرسون اذن
التفسير المتبقي ان يكون الروس قد انسحبوا
ليعطوا الاوكران وداعيهم من الغرب سببا
ادفعهم لبدء المفاوضات يقولون لقد حققنا
انتصارا كبيرا على الروس واستطعنا ان
نسترد جزءا على الاقل من مدينه خرسون التي
اعلن الروس انها جزء من الاراضي روسيا
الاتحاديه الى الابد وبالتالي نستطيع ان
نبدا المفاوضات وتبدا المفاوضات ده احتمال
بس ده هيطرح مجموعه اخرى من الاسئله هل
نوايا الروس ان يبداوا في مفاوضات فعلا
جاد على امل انهاء الحرب بتنازلات من
الطرفين وارد لكن في هذه الحاله هتطرح كيف
ما هي نوع التناسلات التي يمكن ان يقدمها
الرؤوس
الروس قالوا ان الاراضي دي اصبحت اراضي
روسيا الاتحاديه هل يمكن التفاوض على
التخلي عن جزء من اراضي روسيا الاتحاديه
واعاده الاستفتاء من جديد وكم سوف تكون
تكلفه ذلك على مستقبل فلادمير بوتن كيف
يمكن ان يسوق بوتين للشعب الروسي تخليه عن
الاراضي التي قال انها جزء من اراضي روسيا
الاتحاد الاتحاديه
هل انه همم واذا لم يتخلى عن الاراضي هل
يمكن ان يقبل الاوكران بالتفاوض بعد ان تم
انتزاع اربع مدن مهمه او 15% من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه وتستمر المفاوضات بالاضافه الى
عدم المساس طبعا بوضع همم شبه جزيره القرد
هل يمكن ان يقبل الطرفان بالمقترح اللي
تقدم به بعض السياسيين يعني والمراقبين
انه بوتين يعيد يقبل باعاده الاستفتاء على
وضع المدن الاربعه اذا كانت سوف تكون جزءا
من روسيا او تعود الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه
في المقابل اعتراف دولي بانه شبه جزيره
القرم اصبحت روسيه الى الابد لانها الرؤوس
ده امها في 2014 لكن المجتمع الدولي لم
يعترف بها اذا اعترف المجتمع الدولي في
مقابل اعاده الاستفتاء على وضع المدن
الاربعه التي ضمها رسميا في 30 سبتمبر
يمكن للرؤوس يمكن
ان يسوق هذا على انه انتصار داخل الاراضي
الروسيه
احتمالات كثيره مفتوحه ومن بين الاحتمالات
ان الروس يكونوا غير جادين في المفاوضات
او مدركين ان التفاوض غير مجدي خصوصا مع
الطلبات العاليه جدا للاكران
وان المفاوضات ليس الا يعني فرصه لالتقاط
الانفاس حتى يستطيع الرؤوس تنظيم صفوفهم
ويقول الاحتياطي اللي هو ال 300,000 اللي
تم استدعائهم قد استعدوا للحرب بشكل جيد
وبينما هم يتفاوضون والاحتياط يستعد تكون
الشتاء
باجوائها القاسيه قد قد دقت على اوروبا
وارهاقتها ارهاقا شديدا
وتفكك همم التحالف الداعم لاوكرانيا وتكون
الظروف مواتيه اكثر الانتصارا روسي
المساله مراهنه على الوقت من جانب الروس
ومراهنه على الوقت ايضا من جانب الاوكران
اللي هيكونوا استعدوا بدعم غربيه اكثر كل
الاحتمالات مفتوحه لننتظر نرى ويقول لنا
مع هذه الحرب التي تشغل كل العالم حلقات
الاخرى باذن الله اشكركم والى اللقاء